- Good to go?
- Good man, just drinkin' my Vayner H2O.
That's how you do it.
(laughing)
(techno music)
- You look sharp.
Are you, were you on--
- I was just on GMA, yeah.
- How'd it go?
- It was great, man.
I loved talking to Michael.
- Strahan?
- Yeah, yeah, he's a good
guy, really good guy.
- What's going on with you?
- [Man] How's it going?
- Have you guys met?
- No, first time.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] Pleasure.
- Yeah.
We, just a lot going on,
man, we're just thinking,
there's so many categories we can go down,
and it's what's--
- I would argue the biggest thing
you guys should be thinking
about is tripling down
on how you got here.
Something I've been thinking
about you, your bro,
and other, the kinda
top 10, is everybody's
now in a mad dash to
monetize, as they should,
these are remarkably big numbers,
I just don't think you're going away.
And if you're not going
away, my big thing now,
more than ever, is how do you go
way more back to the consumer.
I think, if I heard today, that
you're doing a two hour Q&A live stream
every single day with your
fans, like, Juice with Jake,
and it's like you're
literally just drinking
an apple juice in the morning or
a different juice every morning,
you know, and just two
hours, like real, real,
not even on an entertainment kick.
Just like fucking GMA, even.
Maybe it's weird that I'm bringing this up
when you just went on
the old version of it,
and just like, how you doing, cool,
Sarah, thank you for
that, you dude, remember,
just like real, as if
you were with 20 kids
that have loved you forever,
oh shit, I forgot about
that fucking post, or
like, what has happened to
SallyPants49, she did have three million,
I hope she's doing well.
To me, what I'm feeling right now,
is this is the moment more than ever
to unmonetize and
quadruple down on audience.
While it's underpriced.
While it's underpriced attention,
get as much as you can,
because the monetizing
can be done at any point,
and I just think, everyone's like, again,
having empathy, when
you're young on the ride,
there's a level, the insecurities change.
Insecurities drive so much.
The insecurity now is
can I be a professional,
and build an empire or be a business man
or woman at that level,
you know what I mean?
It's fun to watch.
So I think it's a very special,
interesting time for you
where that's just one thing I would
give a lot of thought to.
The audience has to be the fourth pillar.
Or it needs to be a separate thing.
If Leo's that, then the scarecrow,
let's build out Wizard of Oz, here,
you got the fucking lion, cool,
the scarecrow, or Dorothy
needs to the audience.
If you guys are the cowardly
lion with your strategy,
Dorothy needs to be the audience.
I don't know, this is like,
honestly I'm giving myself
advice as I'm talking to you.
This is always the religion.
And it's an interesting time.
Because you become, bro you become
the next, you become the next Brad Pitt,
this is how it happens.
- Yeah.
- If you're 13 right now,
you're the establishment.
And that new person that
popped last week is you.
- Yeah.
It's just you wake up and it is.
(laughing)
It's funny to think, though.
- I think we're also spending
a lot of time now too
on expanding Team 10
and then verticalize it.
We just launched Team 10 gaming,
and we've got these two kids in Team 10,
they're big gamers, did
a big launch on Twitch,
I think we're gonna see in the next year
that the gaming space--
- Dude we've been on that forever.
- Heavy like lifestyle,
it's gonna move more
into like lifestyle.
- You saw what happened last night.
Last night was the moment it changed.
I've been, like we're putting
together a video right now,
I'm glad to see you're not doing it,
that means Babin's
making a good one, right?
Iris?
- [Iris] Seth.
- Seth, alright.
Seth, Seth.
You better not fuck up this video.
You're doing the Twitch video?
You better fucking annihilate it.
- [Jake] What's it about?
- It's just, this is what's
great about filming yourself,
it's fucking me in 2014, 15, 16, 17
talking about Twitch, and then I made,
I literally landed at 4:30
this morning, I'm like,
alright it happened last night,
the crossover moment, here it comes,
people been asking me
what I think about it,
here's what I think about it.
And it's just gonna be
two minutes of highlights
of me being like Twitch, just like--
- From 14, 15, 16, like all the past cuts.
That's awesome.
- That's what I trade on.
That's what's good about
how I do what I do.
Look the world is your fucking oyster,
no matter all the dumb shit
that happens along the way
over the next five years,
as long as it's not super egregious,
you'll get through that funnel easily.
Where you'll get caught way more than like
burning down a house or whatever,
somebody getting hurt on a prank,
or somebody's feelings getting hurt,
where you'll lose is
you'll be a boa constrictor
that tries to eat an
elephant and you'll blow up.
- Right.
- [Gary] That's exactly
what will happen to you.
- We gotta eat rats.
- [Gary] You need to eat like hippos.
Boas are amazing, but they,
you know those fucking,
I'm sure there's videos online where
they try to eat something
too big and they break.
And they're amazing, they
can eat big ass shit,
and you're amazing,
you're gonna be able to
eat big ass shit, you just
need to be very thoughtful
that you don't try to eat too much
which then blows you up.
- Right.
- I'm with you, man, gaming,
you could talk about gaming, crypto,
VR, AR, merch, food, retail stores,
in a few minutes you're gonna realize that
you and your bro are
basically the Wahlbergs
and let's go after Mcdonalds.
I mean, like, this is all real.
My point of view,
take a good fucking week and go to like
Turks and Caicos and Hawaii
and don't produce content,
and just fucking think,
and then really come to
what is the most exciting
thing we could do,
and let's just spend one
year dismantling that
while in parallel
crushing audience growth,
and all this other shit
will be there forever.
Merch is never gonna go away,
endorsement deals are
gonna only get bigger.
It's all coming.
It's taking a step back
and taking a breath
and realizing it won't
go away especially if
number one, two, and
three is the audience.
- Right, I think we do
a bad job right now,
you do an amazing job of
recirculating old content.
We've got all this Vine content.
- Yes, brother, I know, dude,
by the way, I think we
really are the best at it
right now when I look, and
we're not even good at it.
That's how good it is.
Talking to yourself.
Do you remember, it was funny,
with Logan and the parrot,
when I came to you and I was like
the cartoon kid that you
guys added to Team 10,
actually, we probably have that video,
'cause we filmed that day
when I came to Team 10, right?
Or no?
I wasn't vlogging yet.
Fuck.
But you remember, right?
I literally said to him make a cartoon
I believe in it more than ever now
because of Snapchat's new AR kit,
I think the number one
thing you should do,
number one, 'cause Walt Disney
built a much bigger company
than fucking Vince McMahon,
I'm creating a character like,
and a world of them, you
need to go hard at it.
- [Beau] Yep.
- Good.
- On the content side, I think there's two
big opportunities, a
massive animated platform.
- [Gary] Massive, I think
it's bigger than everything.
- And I think the game show side.
- Beau, I couldn't agree more.
Audience.
It's the only thing that matters.
Think about all the
things we just mentioned
that weren't even emerging a year ago.
Like truly 24 months
ago, back to animated,
we wouldn't be talking about,
you just said animation and
fucking game show, right?
If we're sitting here 24 months ago,
neither one of those things
come out of any of our mouths.
My big thing right now is
when you're king of the hill,
triple down on it.
(mumbling)
More.
I would go back to Jake Paul 0.1 where
it was just about the audience.
Like as much as you can.
And I know you can't go all the way back,
I get it, I get it,
but if I can get ya
70% of that 30% of what
you're actually doing now
your whole world will be different.
Audiences know, just so you know.
They'll never be tricked.
Either you're doing it for them
or you're doing it for yourself.
When you audit your last
three weeks and you think
about how many hours you spent on
what's for you, what's for them,
it doesn't look pretty
and it doesn't look pretty
for any of the A lists
right now in our world.
So, cool.
And it's driven by the
right thing, I get it.
You did that first, you're
trying to make your name
in the next thing, I get it,
but I'm telling you that's
where the secret is.
- I agree.
- Cool, if you guys agree with that,
you can't imagine how
excited I am right now
because I actually think
you guys are super smart,
like I think you might agree,
and you might do something about it,
and you're gonna be,
like I genuinely think
I'm gonna get a text or
a video in four weeks
and you'll be like, "Dude."
Because what's gonna happen,
because you're so good,
and you're so big, and you're so creative,
and if you give a fuck,
it's just gonna compound.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] I don't know.
It's just gonna work.
- I think part of that too is like
going into other parallels like music's
a big thing for me.
- [Gary] I know, I've watched.
- Gonna be jumping into Twitch,
jumping into music.
- Music, Twitch and quadruple downing
on your other things.
Music, Twitch, and quadruple down.
Like I can't imagine what your
Twitter and Facebook game are
but I know they're not good enough.
Because there's no reason.
Just film 'em, just fucking film 'em, bro.
He's so creative, just film him.
You should 24 hours a day
have somebody following you,
here's why, you're gonna
say something smart
or creative or funny or,
when you really get to it,
when you really get smart in my opinion,
when you're there with Strahan,
and you guys have a little
clip in the greenroom,
and then you clip it, and
you run it on Facebook,
against fucking Giant
fans, who are 42 years old,
who love Strahan, there's
a segmentation right now on
Facebook that are Giant
fans, that are the age
when he played, and fans
of Good Morning America.
They're both.
There's 18,000 people, 180,000 people,
you take that clip, and you post it,
and he siphons 8% fans.
Paid collabs.
You hear that?
- Right.
- And what happens when you're this size
is you don't use paid media,
because it's all organic,
meanwhile the paid media's never been--
- So cheap, so fucking cheap.
- So my question becomes, like,
here's what's gonna
happen, I'm gonna end up
becoming the most famous of everybody,
because I'm committed just to audience,
and even though I started further behind,
and not in the perfect zone, I can,
I'm just watching it happen.
- What platform are you tackling the most.
- Instagram, podcasts is huge for me.
I think you should have
top 100 podcast tomorrow.
Nobody in your world has done that,
and like,
Facebook is huge, email.
You should see, you
wanna see something cool?
Look what the fuck these guys are doing.
Come here, let's show you.
This you could annihilate.
(clicking)
Here's what I'm sensing.
The worst part of internet marketing
is starting to bleed into
the influencer space.
It's not gonna become
spammy CDs in the back,
but it's gonna because some sort of thing,
and I think the ones
that can rise above it
and do what I did during the 2000s
and stay above that fray, are the ones
that are gonna win the most,
and right now, everybody's
on tilt of monetization,
without really proper thought
around what that means.
Because when you make that switch,
the audience relationship changes,
and you become more the,
you know, you become more
and
because your relationship is only about
the transactional business,
and the authenticity
and uniqueness of what
you were building on
and why you were able to
win that game goes away.
Selling out.
- Yep.
- Not super complicated.
- I'm excited for you, man,
'cause I just see all
the stuff you're doing,
with the agency and then
what's that turning into
longer term, it's incredible.
- I appreciate it.
Yeah, man, listen, I was in
the prime of my business life,
I'd just invested in
Twitter and FB and Tumblr
and made all that, it was all coming,
they were all going
public, this was a grind.
Building an agency sucks.
I have a real job.
Like I have people, I have a
lot of people to answer to.
I'm like answering to them.
I was on two client calls the
second I landed this morning.
This is me giving you advice based on
actually something I'm doing,
which is built for the long term.
- What do you focus on next
in terms of building out,
is there a category you
wanna go after, is there...
- Anything that matters, right?
Like that whole area, we're
turning into a Twitch studio,
so it's right here.
We made that decision after
I went on a Twitch show
with Hunter Pence, the baseball player,
a couple of months ago.
And the next thing is also--
- Are you gonna be doing it yourself?
- Yeah, like, you coming
through right now,
I might take five minutes and play,
but I'm gonna make it authentic.
Like I don't play the new shit, so cool,
you and I are gonna play like Madden 94.
'Cause that's what I know.
(laughing)
- Right.
- So all these kids, I'm gonna try to
play the tree games I'm good at.
And then let them, be like, cool,
now let me show you another thing,
and they'll kill me in two seconds.
I'm like, fuck.
(laughing)
- How are you thinking
about international?
- A lot.
I mean that's where Facebook I think
you should go all in on.
You can reach audience international.
We're running some ads right now in India.
It's fucking nuts.
I also claim that I'm gonna make myself
the most famous person in Peru just on ads
on Facebook with my content.
I'm gonna do it for like six months
and then just fly to Peru
and see what happens.
I think it's gonna be crazy.
Like that's the kinda stuff
I think you should be doing.
That's where--
(mumbling)
That's where Jerome was very smart.
Like when I would tell, like he,
when I would feed him this,
he would run with it and get it.
He really, he was a good under, like
he had all his natural skills but then
when I would be like do this,
he would understand, remember I was like,
go to globe, remember
when he went to Mexico
and everywhere, I was like go global,
and go collab with everybody.
You have all the leverage.
You have to understand,
here's what I think about
with global if I was a
partner on this team.
I'd be like it's all about
audience, audience matters,
global matters, so time is
our biggest issue, right,
opportunity costs, fuck it.
Let's sit down, let's do the math,
who is the biggest 10
influencers in Brazil, got it.
- Cross collab, shoot the
culture, and the whole thing.
- But you do a month.
- So we're doing a concept.
- When you make a thoughtful plan
to go to India for four
days, and you actually
allocate every minute properly,
and you actually systematically
cross every T and I, like
it's all about efficiency,
we'll take this highway,
we're gonna stop right here,
alright hit up, you know, Honie,
he's gonna meet us there,
we'll do the collab there,
and like it's literally just about--
- It's programmed out, like content.
- In a real way, you know what I mean.
Can I tell you something?
Audience.
You're only as good as
how big that bucket is.
You're upside is not gonna be stopped
by creativity or opportunity,
it's gonna be based,
it's gonna be stopped by audience.
You're gonna tap out.
'Cause you've got your bucket and
it's one of the biggest
buckets in the world right now,
but if you're not filling it up
every time you're doing shit,
you're squeezing it out.
That's what happens to everybody.
You're trading on fame.
Got it?
That's the game.
Lot more for them.
'Cause right now you did a lot for them,
and it's all now being cashed out.
- How do you think about new audience
versus existing audience?
How are you catering to your
existing audience versus--
- You're just doing,
you're just doing stuff
for audience, and you let
them weave in and out.
I don't think about it actually.
I'm just doing the best work I can do,
that I think brings people
value, and let them ebb & flow.
Don't overthink that.
And you're gonna change, right?
You're also in an interesting
time in your life.
When you're in your 20s, or early, like,
you're evolving as a man.
So they're gonna, things are gonna happen.
They happened to me
hardcore when I switched
from wine to business content.
Like, hey wine boy, stay in
your lane was very common.
- Cool
- Cool, gonna bounce.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome, good to see you.
(clapping)
- Appreciate it.
- Good to see you.
(clapping)
- Keep doing it.
- I will, my man.
(mellow music)